me
みなさんこんにちは
尾林なお表と申します
奥は現在奈川県の北端に位置する
奥社のっていう自分が甘いさん生まれて育った場所で生活していてまぁこの先もこの
オプシなので死ぬまで生活していけたらいいなっていうふうに思ってますあとして僕は
鶴と亀っていうこの記者の地域に暮らすじいちゃんとかばあちゃんがいい
尻詰まったフリーペーパーを制作しています
今日ですね自分にとってこのじいちゃんとかばあちゃんがどういう存在なのかっていう
のを
お話できればと思います
まず僕にとってじいちゃんとか婆ちゃんってすごい身近な存在です
僕は
本当に昔からばあちゃん子でした
こう両親が小さい頃から共働きだったのでずーっと子守をしてもらってましたし
ずっと同じ屋根の下で暮らしてきました
だからこうおー友達との会話でも自然にバージョンの話が出てきちゃうくらい本当に昔
から
ばあちゃん子だったんですよね
で今でも自分はばあちゃんのことがすごい大好きです
僕ばあちゃん以外にも大好きなものがありまして
かっこいいもうとかイケてるものっていうのがすごい好きなんですね
僕は1991年生まれの現在24歳で
やっぱりまだまだケツが青い若造なわけです
なのでこう早くかっこいい大人になりたいとかカッコイイ男耐えたいっていう願望
みたいのがありまして
でかっこいいものに興味があるんですね
きっとみなさんもあると思います
男性とか女性とか子供とか大人とか関係なくカッコ妹カスて皆素敵なものに興味がある
と思います
僕も小さいころテレビのヒーローだったりだとかあと
スポーツ先週その後は a
中学校とか高校の時に
hiphop とかストリートカルチャーみたいなものにすごいハマりまして
今でももちろん大好きです
当時田舎で生まれて育った僕には本当に衝撃的で刺激的でした
僕は毎日毎日夜更かしをして雑誌だったりだとかネットとかテレビでそういったかっこ
いいも情報を貪るように吸収してました
当時僕がかっこいいと思って見てたそういった情報ってやっぱり都会的なものがすごく
多かったんですよね
都会のお店だったりだとかやっぱ都会で活躍しているアーティストとか都会でしか売っ
てるものな妹か
当然僕はかっこいいものに飢えてたのでただただ地元の田舎でそういったものを消費し
てるだけじゃ
を満足することができずと海に行きたいというふうになりました
いうことで
方向卒業後の大学進学のタイミングで
と会議でてかっこいいものに囲まれた生活を送るようになりました
ずっと雑誌で見ていたこう行きたかったお店に行ったり行ってみなかったアーティスト
のライブに一体本当に甲本もシックとかなることなく満喫して生活してました
でも都会での生活を始めて二年くらい経った時に何か胸にこうモヤモヤした感情が出て
きました
それは地元を置く志團のことだったりとか
地元多く市の出身である
自分の存在のことでした
僕の正
地元をオプシなのは一般的にいえばやっぱり田舎で冬にはすごい雪が降りますし決して
住みやすい場所じゃないと思うんですね
でもこう
気合ではありませんでした
大好きなばあちゃんもいますし家族もいますし
空気もおいしいですしご飯もおいしいですしやっぱり何より方を自分が生まれて育って
きた場所ですし
a そういった地元と格好良いものを求める自分っていうのがどんどんどんどん高離れ
ていってしまってそれがなんかこう
寂しく感じてしまったりだとかあと単純に高自分っていう存在をないから否定するよう
な感じになってしまったりだとか
あとはもっとこう
地元のことをかっこいいって思ういったいっていう風になったりだとか
こういろんな感情が
大複雑に絡み合ってずっとモヤモヤしてました
でもすぐにはそういった
モヤモヤを解決することはできなくて
その後も大都会での生活を続けていました
でもまぁそんなある日単純に新しくかっこいい服が欲しいと思ったの十大
地元に大学の長期休暇のタイミングであることになったので新しい服を買おうと思った
んですね
でひたぎさんに講師もとに帰るわけですから結構気合い入れてかっこいい服今どんなの
がかっこいいのかなぁって雑誌とかネットとかでいろいろ調べてたんです
そしたらこう柄物でたりに差をつけろとか
vita いいジャケットでかっこよく3第7項を目指しを
目にしたんですね
で
まあまあを自分で気に入ったものをを買って地元に帰りました
で地元に帰るとまずやっぱり僕ばあちゃん子なので
ばあちゃんに最初にただ今はって排除するんですね
おばあちゃんを見るとおばあちゃん全然
地元から離れる前と変わってなかったんですけど
おばあちゃん見てみると地元に帰ってくる前の雑誌の柄物をかっこよくみたいな見出し
となんかちょっとリンクしてあるばあちゃんが着てる葉っぱからめっちゃクっぽいなー
みたいになって
なんかそういうふうに思ったんですねで大日変えれば近所おじいちゃんにも合うわけで
す近所おじいちゃん見てみると
これ
その合うたミリタリージャケットだなぁと思って
すげーかっこいいなっていうふうに思ったんですね
祖父もというときってじいちゃんとかばあちゃんをなんか地味なイメージでしか見
なかったりだとかあとおじいちゃんばあちゃんっていうそのもののイメージしか見て
なかったんですけど
ファッション雑誌だったりとかファッションスナップみたいな目線で見るとコーディ
チャパティちょっと変わった見え方がするなっていうふうに
持ったんですね
こう無地の t シャツにワークパンツ履いたりだとか
あと高全体的に気張らないで自然的な後期こなしだったりとか
あとオーバーサイズでラフな着こなしっていうのが結構僕が好きなストリート
カルチャーとかストリートファッションに通じるところがあるなというふうに思ったん
ですね
栄光パーちゃんたちもすごい校
鮮やかな柄は花がらを超えていきたいだとか
このばあちゃんなんかは上着にもインナーにも
をズボンにも伝統的な和柄が入ってたりだとか
でものばあちゃんはこうちょっと優しい淡いいい
こそ染めたような柄が来てたりだとか
このばあちゃんなんかは本当アーティスティックな高規格のような柄を着こなしてて
結構奇抜な柄を自然に着こなしててかっこいいなというふうに思いだったんですね
当然僕ばあちゃん子ですからこのばあちゃんのからこれ僕も来たいなというふうに思い
ました
それと同時にこのばあちゃんたちが着てる柄を若い人が見つけたら
というふうに映るのかなと思って食器になってやってみたんですね
こればあちゃんの柄アップにした行ったんですけど本当にこう花と
なペイズリーと
エンブレムみたいなのがをなく一緒に重なったすごい面白いからで僕がこうおしゃれな
東京でセレクトショップでかっこいい服を探してる時に何かこういうが柄には出会い
ませんでした
でこれもう少し若い子たちがこう気軽に身につけられるようにこの同じ柄で
バケットハットをつくってみたんですねでを買い方がかぶるとこういう感じであります
全然おかしくないというかかっこいいですよね
おばあちゃんが着てるのと比べても全然違和感が無くお互いかっこよく着ててこのかた
ラッパーなんですけどこのばあちゃんのがラーを身に付けてステージ上でダイブしたり
ラップしてても全然本当に違和感なくすごくカッコ良かったです
それだとこれは近所のおばあちゃんのカーディガンの柄なんですけどこれも僕上品で
凄くかっこいいなと思って
あと若い女性がこの柄を見つけているとをどういう風になるんだろうと思って
本当スカートにしてみました
でこのスカートもうすごい高上品で綺麗に来ていますしお腹
都会のコンクリートの背景にも全然馴染んでて
おかしくないなあというふうに思ったんですね
なんかこうやってやってみてマーコート会にかっこいいものを求めていった自分と
祖父もトンを置く白のおじいちゃんとかばあちゃんのセンスとか感覚って
思ってたよりハナエてないのかなというか遠くないのかなというふうに思うようになり
ました
これは僕の中で一つじいちゃん宅間ハーパーちゃんの見方が変わった衝撃的な出来事
でした
それともう一つ紹介して話があります
僕が住んで奥信濃に抜く言う地域がありましてそこにはの帰ってくれた集団があります
このバーの会話6命区のばあちゃんたち
後6人で結成された平均年齢70歳越えのクリエイター集団なんですけど
あクリエイター集団っていうぐらいですから桜夏に野菜を作っ
たいだとか
作ったものを食べて余ったら高道の駅とか
直売所に言って
で冬の間は農業できないですから
わら細工
秋に米収穫した後に出る花でこういったわら細工を作ったり
甲ストラップを作ったりお土産品とかをし作ったりとかしてこう一年中
ものづくりをしてる bar 者たちなんですね
でもこういった野菜をつくったりは座薬っていうのは
ばあちゃんたちにとってはずーっと昔からやってきたことなんでまぁそんな特別なこと
じゃないですね
僕も最初このばあちゃん達に対しての印象っていうのは全然特別なものをじゃなかった
です
でもある日この花の会のもとにこんなお願いが来ました
東京とか札幌とか京都とかそういったところを敢行しているブラ乳の形30名様ぐらい
が
を置くしなうにも来るからばあちゃんたちこのブラジルの形に向けて
わら細工のワークショップを開いてよというお願いがばあちゃんたちどこにあったん
ですね
黒最初これ聞いたときすごいビックリしたのと同時に
すごい心配になりましたばあちゃんたちは僕らと違って
小学校とかの頃に英語もポルトガル語も勉強したことないですし
国際交流したことないですし海外にもう行ったことない人がほとんどだったんですね
それでしかも
プラージュあった30名に対して通訳の方が一人だけみたいでそれを頃国ばあちゃん
たちが開いてする
しかもわら細工って僕ら日本人がやっても結構難しくて手間もかかりますし時間も
かかるんですね
なんでこれ本当みんな完成までいけるのかなってすごい心配してたんですね
ばあちゃんたち本人は自分以上にもっと心配だったみたいですでも当日
をなんやかんやではラザクのワークショップ開催することになりまして
実際に開催してみるとこれビックリでした
最初やっぱばあちゃんたち緊張してましたし言葉が通じないことに大戸惑ってました
でもですね次第にこういつも通り自然な身振り手振りだったりだとか
言葉遣いで一生懸命バージョン形に教えるを教えているようになって a その結果
短い時間の間だったんですけどラージョンウたちみんな終わらザク完成することができ
まして
でこのバラ酒歯難しかったですから完成したとブラジャーの方たちもすごい喜んでて
で完成した後はお疲れ様ということで
こうやって普段から僕ら食べてる別に特別なもうじゃないんですけど今目立ったりだと
か
付もうとかおひたしとか妹の5個をご馳走して振る舞ってあげて
で食べてもらったんですね
day ワークショップ終わってみると本当にダイソー
大成功でもう皆さん喜んでくれて一緒に記念撮影したりかありファッションへ始まっ
たりだとかあ最終的には大雪の上とか畳の上とかお構いなしにサンバを踊り出したいと
かして
動い楽しんで皆さん書いてくれたんですね
中には日本のいろんなとこもあってきたけど温いって柱地域が一番面白かったよなんて
言ってくれる方もいたみたいです
僕はこの日ずっとばあちゃんたちと一緒にいたんですけどすごい不思議な気持ちになり
ました
僕は方小学校中学校と英語を勉強してきて国際交流みたいなこともして
で大学の時にはアメリカに行ってホームステイもしましたし
授業でグローバル戦略みたいなことも勉強しました
でもそういったことをやってないばあちゃんたちの方が僕なんかよりもよっぽど上手に
国際交流してたように見えました
しかもずーっと昔からやってるまぁ工芸だったりとか
わら細工だったりとかいつも食べてる
こう地元の手料理みたいなものを特別じゃないものを振る分待ってちょいかも
村字の形で喜んでもらって3番までもを吐露しちゃって
すごいかっこいいなって思いました
僕はもうこの時地元に対して面白くないとか
かっこよくないとか祖母の会とかあの
ファッションかっこいいファッションの g 者とかばあちゃん
のきっかけによってもそういうことは全然思わなくなりました
その結果大学卒業後かっこいいものを追い求める自分のまんま
地元記者のに持ってきました
かっこいいものを追い求める自分と地元奥信濃おじいちゃんとばあちゃんが繋いでくれ
ました
皆さんは格好妹かカッコイープラしてどういうことだと思いますか
僕は都会の方がかっこいいとか小脳がカッコイイとか
若者よりおじいちゃんとかバージョンをカッコいいとかそういうことじゃないと思い
ます
じいちゃんとかバージョン見てて思うのは結局こうかっこいいものとかって人それぞ
れって事だと思うんですけど
じいちゃんとかバージョン見てて思うのは
やっぱ自分らしく自分たちらしくその歳で生きるって事だと思いました
今の時代こう新しさだったり変化だったりそういったものに
を求めがちだったりそういったものに目が行きがちだったりとかしてしまうんですけど
も意外とかっこいいものとか
そのきっかけってー身近なところ足元にあるような気がします
じいちゃんばあちゃんのプラ手も
高級なものだったり最先端なものが目の前にあるような暮らしではないです
そうではなくてずーっと慣れ親しんできた家族だったりだとか
自然だったりだとか
手料理だったりとかそういうものを大切しながらこう生きていく生活です
まぁそうやって聞くと一見行為中にのんびり3スローライフみたいに感じるところも
あると思うんですけどもやっぱりじいちゃんとかばあちゃんは僕らに比べて圧倒的に
不便で不自由な時代を
雪が降る奥したのでやっぱり
こう生きてきたわけですから
力強くてたくましくて凄くかっこいいですよね
でもだからといって
僕がその爺ちゃんとかばあちゃん同じような暮らしです
すればかっこよくなるかといったらそうじゃないと思います
ぼくにはぼくなりの便利で自由な
地方で生きてきたからこその小倉 c 暮らしっていうのがあると思います
そして僕はこれからそういう生活をこの奥したので
していけたらいいなって思っています以上です今日ありがとうございました